36 ساعه كتمروس فيها انفاسهم طبخ بوتين
اعلن ان وجهته ستكون العاصمه موسكو بعد ان
سقطت المدن على طريقه واحده تلو الاخرى
لكن حاكم الكريم اوقف الانقلاب ليتنفس
الروس سعداء ماذا حدث خلال تلك الساعات
الحاسمه في تاريخ روسيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صباح يوم الجمعه بتاريخ 23 من يونيو
ظهر قائد فاجن ارياف ليعلن الانقلاب ضد
بوتين متهما الجيش الروسي بقتل قوته وفي
صباح السبت 24 من يونيو دخلت فاغنر
الاراضي الروسيه بعد انسحابها من اوكرانيا
واعلن قائدها سيطرته على مدينه روستوف وفي
نفس اليوم اكملت فاجنر توغلها شمالا
باتجاه العاصمه موسكو هنا
ظهر الرئيس بوتين في خطاب رسمي وجهه للامه
قائلا انما يحدث هو طعنه في الظهر وتوعد
بريكوجين بالرد الساحل
[موسيقى]
بعد ساعات من خطاب بوتين اعلنت فاجنر
وصولها لمدينه ايليت التي تبعد عن موسكو
حوالي 400 كلم وهنا دخل الرئيس بيلاروسي
الكسندر لوكاشينكو على الخط وعرض على صفقه
لوقف تقدم قواته والعوده من حيث اتت
[موسيقى]
استجاب لعرض لوكاشينكو وعاد ادراجه ثم
اعلن مغادره اروستوف وسط حمايه مشدده دون
تدخل من الدوله اما قوته فتراجعت الى
معسكراتها
[موسيقى]
وبموجب صفقه لوكاشينكو سينقل بريكوجين الى
بيلاروسيا وسيتم اسقاط التهم الجنائيه عنه
بواسطه بيلاروسيه وبضمانات من الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لتطوى بذلك صفحه
ربما ستعيد حسابات الكريملين كلها خصوصا
في هذه المرحله الحرجه التي لا تزال فيها
الحرب مستعره في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]